as long as he's
are you
[Music]
1974 was his first two months
that's the first photo
is
i move that we don't accept that right
good afternoon councillors members of
the staff um the screen is a
stream is underway so anybody who's
joined us on that welcome along uh for
this meeting of the performance policy
and partnerships committee uh on zoom uh
lindsay mckenzie and pania cook
councillor crackit will be joining us
soon
uh and we have an apology from
councillor abbott would somebody like to
move that that's received councillor
lewis and councillor sopa i'll put that
all in favor
against kerry
no items of public forum
uh so
we'll move into the minutes of
performance policy and partnerships
from uh december 14 where somebody'd
like to move they're touring correct
i'll move those
councillor partners seconded
councillor edmondson
your matters are rising
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried
councillor lewis that brings us to the
well-being fund committee i'm happy to
move those minutes be a true and
reckless of that meeting thank you to
you
thank you second councillor kit any
matters arising
thank you
put the motion all in favor aye aye aye
against
carried
the extraordinary meeting of performance
policy and partnerships from
december 21st
i'll move there a true and correct
record i'll second that
thanks councillor soper
any matters rising from that
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried
which brings us uh on to the performance
report for the six months patricia do
you wanna and
jamie do you wanna grab the
norton chairs
thanks councillors i trust you've had a
chance to have a read through anything
in particular that you're wanting to
draw our attention to
um
really because this is the half-year set
of accounts so this is the closest sort
of most easiest look we get to see what
we've done for the last six months
to show that actually
we are still operating on a net
operating surplus for that first six
months it's a little lower um than we
forecast
but we um are still the forecast going
forward
is still looking good to be where we
wanted to be on plan
um we didn't know there was some income
that was just a timing issue wasn't
there so the nzta claim for december um
from a capital perspective
um
the forecast's been adjusted down now to
57.3 million for the year's delivery um
that's against their planned amount of
70
73 million
but we have a number of big projects
which we expect will um
ramp up in this last half of the year
that being stead street and the city
block and the city streets
first stage so they will help that
delivery
but
um we do note that the delivery of the
some of the pipe renewal project the
renewal work in three waters area is um
less
than um
would have been desirable at this time
of the year so there is still some
challenges in that space
thank you other than that from uh kpi
performance levels of service everything
there's some improvement on the last
quarter
but it's pretty much the same again
jamie anything you'd like to add
um just on the capital side of things so
um
we are ahead of where we were last year
so last year um we were sitting about 11
million
at this time of year um so this year
we're at 19. um and
normally
q3 eq4 is our busier periods so we do
normally get a good ramp up
um subject to um getting contractors as
you'll see with um an
they're quite well below the where they
would normally be this time of year and
contractors are getting them lined up to
do the work seems to be the
biggest issue in that space at this
stage
um the only other thing i'd like to add
is just on the recommendations
under four
and the third bullet point says
restatement of the operating balances it
should be restatement of the opening
balances
well thank you
malavik if you can make that adjustment
so all things considered bearing in mind
covered interruptions that effect on
revenue
the tightness of operating in
in the contracting market
actually it's not bad
um
down a little bit on where we were and
there's still i guess no
indication of what's likely to happen
over the next couple of months we're in
there that heavy period of contracting
work now i know that we've had resellers
working outside our house they were i
initially thought it was a
an error on the big lighted sign that
said uh 6
pm to 6 a.m
but no it wasn't
uh that said they the crew that was on
was super efficient it was only one
night that i
kind of really noticed them but you know
they're looking at these other options
that
affect traffic management stead street i
think there was some
hole-ups prior to christmas but it seems
to be progressing
really well
apart from the traffic inconvenience of
course
um
but the things that we need to be wary
of uh set within the report is somebody
interested in moving the uh five
recommendations noting that change to
operating opening balances rather than
operating balances
prepared to move that way move
councillor secretary ms cook
questions councillors
councillor amundsen
thanks um
one of the reasons i think we started
with the road map was so that we could
easily update the community about where
the various projects are at and on it's
page 27 of board books i'm not sure
which page but it's got the
diagram with all the projects and stuff
are we able to put something like that
out through our social media or
something just to let people know so
that they or put it on our website so
that people can have a direct link to go
to look
to see how things have progressed over
the last six months since approving the
annual long-term plan
yeah i think this is the plan is to put
in the website so we do have that
communication out um and because it's
our first time it's in the report that
we'll get that onto the website as soon
as we can
thanks council anderson
any other questions
councillor clark
uh just referring to uh boardwalks are
those that want to scroll through on
page 26
there's a 3.2 million dollar um
difference between
forecast and actual expenditure
is is this the is in the line of
subsidies and grants is this the nzta
subsidy that you're referring to earlier
on report
so is that all all that 3.2 is that
and is that likely to kick in in the
next quarter
um half of it is to do with the ncaa
because i've seen in the other half is
the timing of money we get through the
three waters and the shovel ready coming
in okay on page 28
um and it refers to the museum long-term
planning having 52.5 million dollars set
there in the ltp does that include the
storage or is that just the museum
so that was what was planned that was
what was discussed in the autism
okay
um
on page 57 it talks about there's a
commentary there about hewakatuya and it
talks about the digitalization of access
to the collection
is this is this referring to the overall
museum collection or are you talking
about
just what's held by hewakatuya and its
partners
that's the full collection all
collection okay
and on page um 66 i i just need some
clarification on the commentary and i'll
read it here because i don't understand
what it actually what it actually says
it says
subsidies revenue funding time dependent
on progress of southern museum and art
gallery projects so
i'm not sure what that actually means
so that's um you said the fourth the
forecast on the subsidies and grants
line was 179 000
of revenue
what we've had none to date
um
and that's because that is all dependent
on the timing of the project so because
some subsidies put in there in relation
to that project which hits this activity
okay fine and just one last question
which is on page 71
where we have a line on borrowings
and you've got a near
89.5 million dollars just want to be
clear in my mind
that that's against a new zealand
funding
agency's ceiling of around about 280 300
million
why i don't want a precise figure but is
it reasonable to say that at the moment
um we have up to three times our income
stream as a potential borrowing level
from the nz
funding agency
three it's either two and a half or
three yeah i think it's three but i
think they're talking about scrolling it
back to 2.8 yeah
so that that's quite a positive result
and that gives us some margins that we
can potentially play with if we wish to
at a late stage
because that's under a third of what we
could be potentially borrowing
correct yep thank you that's cool
mr day
thank you through yourself cheer um just
wanted to remind councillors yes that is
280 that is available through
uh local government funding but a
reminder that the current um
covenant and under
icc is at 150 so just want to remind us
of that
council clerk just just for a reflection
on what michael just said that that
restriction we have of 150
that could change by the will of uh
council though
am i right michael yes through the chair
that is correct okay thank you
it is a self-imposed covenant yeah thank
you
any other questions
okay we go back to the
recommendations this is the five of them
as mentioned and demanded move by
councillor sopa and ms
if there are no other questions or
comments i'll put the motion all in
favor
all right
against
carrie
thank you for that
which brings us on to the activities
reports
mr chair counsellors
so we'll take the report as read
but i also want to highlight a couple of
matters in particular
there is some incorrect dates on the
property records
numbers they are actually 2022 so
apologies we have a new team leader and
um
the first time for reporting but i can
assure you
that the limbs and property file
requests continue to come ahead
one disappointing factor for us was the
percentage of non-notified resource
consents not completed within the
statutory 20-day time frame i can assure
you the team is well across this and
looking at solutions
to improve this number up from
a low of 57
off the top of my head and we are
undertaking a review of the processes
as well to make sure it's not just a
linear process but it has some
flexibility
to combine different workflows but
welcome any questions so that process is
underway now truly that's correct
just um
in the next section for uh
leisure and recreation
um
having a look at some of the figures
around the library
uh remote services um seen an increase
look i just wanted to check on that
figure um the my book bag figure which
is great it's good that our services are
still able to continue through the red
traffic lights and notice that south and
district councils are all online
um
933 makes great reading when you boil it
down though to um
three the previous year to 31
in this last year
um
is the 933 right stick
um
i can
i can double check with the team but
i think one of the things we've seen
over the past
12 months in particular is a quite a
significant shift
to a different way of operating
and
you know
12 13 14 months ago we didn't have a
need for a
an online service nearly as much as we
do now and i think that the point i was
going to make to
this report is actually the significant
effort that is going into our services
under this new cover protection
framework and this is representative of
that effort going into ensuring we're
continuing to make our collections
available i know there are a lot of
extra services that have been introduced
at the library which have had to go on
hold but they have looked
creatively how they're able to continue
to provide for the new audiences that
they've created um so the fact that
they're working on that's really good
you know the
summer reading program for example i
remember our kids were hugely interested
in that and it's good to see that
they've been able to continue to provide
those
good that those
services continue and looking at how
some of the interaction with the
community of the story walk for example
um looking at what's going on within the
cbd
um
i think the new trending collection was
another thing that's reflected in the
report what are the high demand books
and getting more copies of them to
reduce waiting time so you know looking
at how they sharpen what they do is
really encouraging
any questions or comments from
councillors on any part councillor clark
yeah just in relation to page 82 which
refers to uh collection storage
and it makes reference to a new policy
that
there's some rationalization of the
collection and the rehousing and i'm
okay with that
the question i have i guess is
how much of the current
collection has been catalogued given
that last year the figure was five
percent
um through you mr chia look
as much as the cataloging is occurring
we're also identifying
the scale and the scope of that
collection as its entirety
and it's um look the percentage is a
shifting number unfortunately i can't
give you a hard and fast figure of it's
now six percent or seven percent or 70.
um
the team are working through a number of
external consultants to assess the scale
and the scope of our collection
working with the smag board and making
sure that the awareness is there of the
size
and putting that program in place for
when and
if we
need to move and pack that collection up
counselor clark just as a follow-up
question to that and maybe uh might be
helpful given that we've got a meeting
on the 15th of february which is a week
away
um about the museum going forward it
would be helpful to know whether it's
six seven or seventy percent
because one of the debates that we'll
get into is
should we categorize catalog
um a collection before we move it or can
we move it and subsequently catalog it
somewhere else so
i'm not trying to put steve on the spot
at the moment but having a response
to uh
my original question by the following
meeting would be helpful
thank you heads up their counsellor
any other questions or comments on the
items in the activities report
if not i'll move the reports received if
there's a second one
people do that councillor sopa thank you
and if there are no further issues i'll
put the resolution all in favor
against
carried
castles that's all we have an open
meeting we'll be going to receive a
couple of items in public excluded
so at this point i'll thank those who've
joined on